good luck have fun
well that's a shame i'm donating a
charity okay i'm too busy to
to play your stupid video games all
right
i should try to donate don't worry about
it i've just tried to donate i'm just
trying to donate
stop it okay priorities you know
okay oh my god
and then yeah and then and then and then
did we do it
did i die did i do the thing yeah
what
[Laughter]
are you guys serious guys you gotta do
the emergency stuff you gotta come
together i didn't
i did the oh my god it was like a
millisecond too late
that's the best win ever oh
my god stella
that's the most pro the fastest win i've
ever had in the history we're really
good
we're really good i would like you guys
to know that that entire time i was
putting in my details to donate and then
i
literally submitted the donation and
then i was like wait wait what
yeah the entire cat is wondering
what the hell is happening
i sabotaged it and uh i just ran around
and i guess
you guys ready ready let's do it jump
into it all right let's go
follow you all right
my face was too obvious then i know that
i'm not seeing any of their faces but i
know that um
uh khalifa's just is totally looking at
it so
no i got it but i would like to be
witness to do it
that's the okay
we caught this isn't gonna happen again
okay
all right
now i know that i'm about to come out of
the gate
just throwing around accusations this
isn't an accusation it's a question
mm-hmm blessing where did you come from
i came from medbay i was there with him
he got scanned i saw it
yeah greg saw me get scanned okay and i
understand your suspicion though because
i did
run right past you when you just found
the body and so yeah no that's the only
reason
okay so if if greg can vouch i've
actually um
it wasn't it was in storage by the by
the gas can
uh that's all the info i've got
okay i did uh o2
who did the other side of o2
i was there with i think a
few people i think khalif was there we
were all running in there just to make
sure this is maybe too fast
voting time is way too short oh we
balanced in the opposite direction
oh too much too much okay i like how i
first
i don't know why i did that
i was
[Music]
okay well you know that's helpful that's
all i'm gonna say
that sure is helpful i'm just gonna
pretend to need to do this one
all right we could do lights nice wack
mate
that's all fine that all seems fine
i just tried to hit that button and
failed so
so that's cool um
[Laughter]
god oh my god it's a lot of vodalana i
saw her kill
she called she killed blessing i was
running without a lana kill blessing
i was just in security and i walked out
and down i don't even know what you're
[ __ ] talking about are you serious
i was just in security ethan would have
seen me in security ethan
greg you're you're lying you're you're
lying
100 just together in security 100
percent i left i have no idea what
you're talking about
i have not seen a square that is
[ __ ]
i saw alana kill my bet you know they're
a liar
blessing when they say i've never lied
about anything he says i've never lied
about you've never lied to this game
really i have not lied once in this game
roll back to tape craig
we'll pause
miss greg i didn't see i did not see
a thing get out of here oh my god you
guys are stupid idiots you deserve to
lose
which would be your stupid morons i was
natural nobody vouched for greg
chuck so does it only tell
okay but i need to just throw this
because that was way too suspicious of
me
i need to just 100 get thrown
all right i accept your apologies
shirts no no don't even come at me that
way
never have i lied not in one game when i
was the murderer that's why it's a bad
defense
it just doesn't make sense i have never
lost this game i find it disgusting and
i refuse to do it
makes a good point i don't know i killed
like three people oh my god
no i know that but like how did he think
that uh
i just i i don't know i'm so excited
when alana killed me
because i was like we got her red-handed
it's over for her that's what i thought
i walked out loud and then i was like
no one else was around i'll be fine no
one else was there
i totally got this yeah
oh amazing i'm sorry greg but mostly not
you all deserve that loss
okay okay
all right cool
just gonna you know just sort of do this
again i guess for the third time in a
row
what could go wrong what
could go wrong
i don't wanna do it i'm going to be here
first too and that's what
someone should always witness me okay
yeah let's do it
done
okay god damn
i don't know what to do i could do that
i guess
and then i could do this i guess
that was a risk
i know i've taken so long that it's just
stupid oh god okay fine
i don't didn't like any of that okay
gonna
go do lights
is blessing glitching or is he walking
strangely
all right we did the lights we have
several alibis
what what what what what oh my god what
how did that even happen we were like
yeah no it's totally done and then it
was not that at all
i'm gonna out blessing for feeling like
he's been following me is what i'm gonna
do
just so everyone knows
i should've done that they're all like
kind of a way okay
cool okay get out get out get out get
out get out get out get out get out
oh gosh
[Laughter]
um i found i found ethan
uh excuse me blessing we found him me
and greg
[Laughter]
blessing i did want to ask a question
i felt like you were really following me
and not doing much at the start
i felt like you would i felt like i was
being chased around by you
we got five at the start like you tried
to join our our
crew yeah and then like mike tried to
join the crew with them that makes sense
kind of funny crew wouldn't yeah
i was i was feeling very happy and then
we somehow screwed up the lights and i'm
really not sure how that happened
i think that was my fault because like
what we were we were doing at the same
time
yeah i took the same one and i think it
went on and off um at the start i went
straight to like one node and was like
standing at that node and doing that one
and greg can vouch for me because i know
he was right there with me uh anyway i
found the
body on the uh bottom left side of the
map inside that one building all the way
to the left i never know what it's
called
nero too um i don't think it was greg i
don't think we'll still make mike
i don't think i don't even feel like
it's me seeing anyone over there i
i was just right next to no but keem and
i were right next to each other next to
like the center building just now
okay so just just so we know kind of one
of these there's three of us
and then three of them so you know we
got to take a look here
okay where were you at i was doing my
little card that i had to flip over and
scan
you guys i went into that room i did see
her yeah i didn't see her i didn't see
anybody being weird
i did see blessing following alana
around because i was trying to follow
alana around
oh hey thanks appreciate that but it was
weird blessing it was weird
it was it was shaky i do not call
following you
that's convenient there wasn't her
following us
okay okay why would you do that i don't
know where you are
okay yep uh-huh katie is one of my good
graces we're going after aladdin keem
i'm sorry
i am
very upset with greg for what he just
did there
um because he didn't have to
have a blessing like that uh
he just like by doing that i didn't
stand a chance
you know why did he
do that
that was like he was like no that didn't
happen
rov two people were like
onto him like kate noticed why did craig
you know it was like i feel like the
game's done and they're just going to
win now and
we don't stand a chance oh my gosh
they're getting the tasks done hard we
need to but then greg is going to be
following someone around so
what's the plan here miller i think
maybe i gotta be more reckless i'm just
gonna get the
freaking tasks done
okay
well i could just do that who cares
really you know
it's fine i'm sorry kate seagull
so i didn't see anything go down i just
think it's keem
okay okay okay yeah and actually this is
a this is a good place to call it
because we haven't voted anybody out
which means yeah i'm still
imposters and so the next person that
dies that ends the game i think it's
keem because keem will just stand in
there i think we all saw him just like
blessings let me finish let me finish
i'm confident man keem i i love you the
homie let me finish
you were standing still you're standing
still outside the building
and that's when the sabotage happened no
no no you sound way too cute
that tells me you're in the menu
pressing this happens leads me to
believe that you're the imposter
whenever someone sounds so sure no i saw
him scan he was
he's not the opposite he's often right
when he tells you who's the killer
like i scanned that little disc that
drive you know floppy disk drive thing
with my face on it i scanned that thing
and then i went and
did some electrical i'm still trying to
get used to this particular map so
that's why
okay to be clear the last time we played
i played this exact map with keem
so now
that's all that's getting me there's the
deal here's the deal dead to right you
have
the kind of funny crew which is blessing
and greg you have me in the middle
you two versus those two on the swing
vote here how am i not also
technically kind of funny crew is all
i'm saying okay i mean
right now kind of money crew you
murdered me numbers of times a lot of
fears that doesn't mean that i'm not
technically a little bit of a part of
that crew
okay here's the big deal here's the deal
if you two need to swing vote you need
to convince
me here because if not i have to vote
with greg and blessing and that means
keem's out
and then we're coming for you alana
they're gonna stick together no i voted
for keem if you don't vote me i'll i'll
i'll get you a new oh you voted for keem
yeah oh i freaking love you i was like
no before you and if she says
before you i gotta go what are you gonna
turn down back in alana
guys just a quick update we're at 12k
now
we have how many how many more minutes
is that six
skip this six more minutes and we're
trying to get to thirteen pounds
okay
[Laughter]
he's uh
[Music]
he was following me the whole time i got
i got some
beef we won anyway but greg why on earth
did you side with blessing when i was
putting guilt on him and everyone went
for it you were like nah he's cleo why
would you do that
you're like
you're bulletproof everyone just loves
you and they're gonna believe you no
matter what you say you got out of it
we won don't worry always a good vote to
vote for alana it's
always a good vote i know it was a lot
cause a lot of was like saying just
random things about me like oh i saw you
follow me
i don't think i ever followed you no you
were following me it didn't happen
when she's the imposter